comienza una nueva era para finlandia y
suecia como consecuencia directa de la
invasión rusa de ucrania los dos países
solicitan conjuntamente su ingreso en la
otan
es firefox o suecia y finlandia han
acordado a participar en el proceso codo
con codo y presentamos juntos nuestra
solicitud a la otan es una respuesta
contundente hay una clara señal de que
seguiremos unidos en el futuro
pero la adhesión a la otan representa un
proceso que podría ser largo luego de
que los países solicitantes en este caso
finlandia y suecia oficialicen su
solicitud deben esperar a que el bloque
les extienda una invitación para
comenzar las negociaciones
una decisión que debe tomarse de manera
unánime por todos los países miembros
por lo que la negativa de turquía a
aceptar la adhesión jugaría un papel
importante en el proceso pero si se
logra superar este obstáculo las
negociaciones iniciarían en bruselas y
ahí se analizará entre otros puntos la
capacidad de los candidatos en materia
de defensa y otros asuntos legales los
candidatos deben comprometerse a llevar
a cabo los cambios necesarios y enviar
un comunicado al secretario general de
la otan donde se incluye calendario para
la aplicación de las reformas sugeridas
el último paso es la ratificación del
protocolo de adhesión una vez concluye
la negociación la otan redacta el
documento de ingreso al tratado de
washington luego los 30 aliados cada uno
tiene que firmar y ratificar el texto
una vez concluido este paso el
secretario general de la otan invita a
los candidatos a ingresar y el ingreso
finaliza una vez los candidatos también
ratifican el acuerdo mediante sus
procesos internos